hello everyone and welcome to another
game we'll be showing from the final
round of the 2021 tata still tournament
it's world champion magnus carlson
against maxine vasher and maxine bashar
lagrave and um
it's incredible that the two of them are
meeting in the final round but it
doesn't matter which one of them wins
they will not be winning this tournament
so that's uh
uh pretty incredible as the magnus is
the world champion and maksim vashir
lagrav
is currently leading the candidates
tournament alongside janipanishi
so uh this is quite the the upsetting uh
of uh you know just something we we
couldn't even imagine when the
tournament started
uh but it does uh matter for the
tournament standings as
uh for for those players who are leading
the tournament it depends on how well
of course maxim and magnus do in the
tournament for their own standings
uh something uh like an additional
criteria
so without further ado let's check it
out and the magnus and maxine will again
have another theoretical debate about
none other than the groomfield defense
so let's see what's happening here
magnus with the white pieces opens with
d4 and we have
knight to f6 and for those of you who
haven't seen the previous videos um
in the series uh how the groomfield is
challenged when magnus plays against the
maxim
i will put some links in the description
below i think there's like three or four
of them so far
but okay d4 knight f6 we have c4 uh g6
knight the c3 and the d5 so just the
main line of the groom
we have c capture sunday five night
captures and e4
so just forcing the knight to either
move back or to capture on c3
capturing on c3 is the absolute main
line what maximum always plays and now
bishop to g7 and here bishop to c4 or
knight to f3
are the most usual moves but magnus goes
for the very early queen to a4 with
check now asking maxim what do you want
to do want to block with the bishop with
the knight or whatnot
maxine blocks with the queen he says i'm
very happy trading queens here you will
simply help me develop my pieces and the
magnus goes queen to a3
now saying uh if you go queen to d6 i
don't care because
if you capture then you are helping me
develop my pieces
so here b6 uh maxine prepares the fiance
to the light square bishop
and now knight to f3 just continuing
development
and now in the spirit of the groomfield
striking in the center with c5 so white
has to be very careful
that rook is still on a1 so bishop to e3
and interestingly
uh envel already had this position twice
in uh 2019
feed a grand prix in riga uh he played
against shakhir mahmudarov and
mamidyarov
continued with bishop to d3 in both of
the games but here
magnus goes bishop to e3 and it is
already as a move tender we have a
completely new game
so let's see uh how mvl continues he
castles here
and now comes rook to d1 just getting
the rook
away from that nasty a1 square putting
the rook on the same file as the queen
and only now maxime trades in the center
captures captures and the queen to d6
offers a queen trade now
but as an end result he will get an
isolated d6 pawn so captures captures
and then now magnus shifts the rogue
back to c1
maybe already we could have a nice rook
lift with the rook to c7 but
first bishop to b7 preventing this
because the e4 pawn is undefended and
now
bishop to d3 magnus defends it and now
knight to c6
just continuing development uh and
magnus says i'm not castling here i'm
leaving my king in the center of the
board the queens are of the board i'm
going to be very safe here
and only then will i bring my other rook
into the game
or maybe i won't so here rook ate the c8
and
magnus now goes h4 and this is pretty
standard stuff in modern chess
uh you will always pretty much play if
your opponent castle kings
h5 h6 is uh is what's now it's
it's what's meta nowadays so here
knights to b4
with an attack on the a2 pawn also
pressuring the bishop here magnus goes
back defends against both of these
threats
and now rook c the e8 shifting the
attention towards the e4 pawn
and here sorry about the arrow this is
the arrow and now we have a3 magnus
pushes back the knight
knights to c6 and now bishop to a2
here magnus says okay you are welcome to
grab that e4 pawn but if you do that i'm
playing bishop to d5
and good luck surviving that but these
are exactly the kind of positions that
maksim enjoys playing and he already
has a pretty bad tournament i think this
is probably his worst tournament
uh in i don't even remember uh
if uh from when i heard of maxime that
he had a tournament this bad
uh so here this is basically what magnus
is offering and maxine goes for it
rook captures an e4 he grabs the pawn
and will give up the exchange but uh he
will have the
mighty bishop fair so let's see what he
had in mind bishop to d5
now with an attack on the rook and a
double attack on the knight here
knights the a5 and here bishop captures
we have bishop captures
now his bishop pair is uh very very
strong here i wouldn't say
uh fully operational just yet but they
are uh
they are very strong and here rook the
c7 magnus gets this
wonderful rook lifting and now uh you
could defend it with rook to a7 but you
don't want to
do that too soon so first a6 and now
h5 magnus continues now pushing of
course he doesn't mind if the the g
file opens up then he gets the h file
open for his rook as well
so b5 by maxine now preparing to move
the knight maybe create a nice pass pawn
on the queen side
and h sorry h6 by white now uh as it was
planned all along with bishop to f6 and
now bishop to g5 magnus wants to trade
off at least one of the bishops
because then without the bishop pair you
don't really have all that much so
maximum of course avoids that
bishop to h8 and now rook to h4
putting pressure on the light square
bishop bishop to d5
and now king to c3 we have
knight to c4 and here we have knights to
d2
offering a trade of knights but also
asking are you maybe interested in
another pawn
and as we often said uh maxine enjoys
grabbing those pawns so he goes for a
knight captures an a3 a very bold
decision now he created two connected
pass pawns here on the queen side
but uh what was carlson's plan here
magnus goes
king to b4 he attacks the knight forces
it to go back to c4
knight to c4 and now knight captures on
c4 and now his idea is if b
captures on c4 to get this past pawn
he's just gonna play bishop to e7 and
black really has no no good moves uh
and you are you are much too uh much too
slow for example if rook to b8 check
you're gonna block the past pawn and now
again this is being threatened
what do you play here if you go after
something like uh
rook to b3 check king c2 you have to go
back because
uh well you're going to get checkmated
the pawn is guarding the
the g7 square so it would be a
completely winning position for white
so instead bishop the c4 was played and
now bishop to e7 by magnus
uh we have rook to e8 and now rook to f4
maybe maybe asking or you may be
interested in saving the pawn but then
exposing your uh your f7 pawn uh maxime
says all right we're gonna
start with f5 and now comes g4 by magnus
so just going after that weakness and
now
it doesn't really matter what you play
here you could try and maybe go rook
captures on e7 rook captures but
uh and then maybe start pushing those
pawns but there's just no way to start
pushing them
uh this dark square bishop is completely
boxed in and the
the the king is completely uh stopping
uh white
black's complete uh play on the queen
side so nothing to be done here really
so after
this g4 move we have king to f7 maxim
tries to activate the king
but not just the bishop captures on d6
with check king the e6
and the bishop to c5 uh we have bishop
to f6
uh ending out g captures on f5 with
check
g captures and now rook the c6 with
check we have king to f7
and now comes rook captures on f5 so
preparing to win that bishop here
but now just rook to e6 and maxime says
all right
we're gonna trade uh rooks here uh and
then i'm gonna try and do something like
bishop maybe here after i move my king
push a5 a4 maybe there's some counter
play here
however the position is completely
winning for white so feel free to pause
the video here and
win the game for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
pawn push
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's d5
so like we said if you trade here just
captures captures then
black still has the bishop pair he can
just move the king start pushing those
pawns
white is still winning here of course
but it's just going to be much much
much much better or even better the king
captures forcing the rook to move so
it's going to be it's going to be better
for white but black will
have some some chances however here
after rook to e6
magnus just played the d5 and it was in
this position that maxine vashila
reside decided to resign the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
so whatever you do if you go rook
captures uh
if you go rook captures on c6 for
example then d captures on c6
and then white is just winning there's
there's no stopping this and it would be
it would be a pretty pretty terrible
game uh
no point in continuing this and of
course maksim knows this so he already
had a bad tournament he probably just
wanted to get this game over with
and the focus on maybe continuing the
candidates tournament if that ever
happens
so and maybe it's also one of the
reasons why maxine was playing so bad in
this
event because he doesn't know what's
happening with the candidates will he
continue being the leader will it start
over will they
what not i don't know will they include
their job of in the next one
uh and maybe maybe even he doesn't want
to uh
show off his preparation during this
tournament because then he can't use it
in the candidates
so a lot of things to consider or maybe
he just downplayed this completely in
in case he maybe wins the candidates and
then he wants magnus to feel very
confident
confident going into a match against
maxime so who knows
what's happening here but maybe it's
just uh maxime
not feeling very motivated he played his
uh groomfield and then
you know i think pretty much in the last
four classical games he played the
groomfield against magnus magnus just
one
but i will put some games in the
description below so do check out them
as well if you're also interested how to
play
against the groomfield defense uh so
yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it i'll keep you posted on
what's happening in the event and who
will
take first place uh i would like to
thank jeff norris aditya suresh kumar
jericho
kevin huang and caitlin quinn for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of what's left of the tata
steel checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day